medical supplies flown from China
arrived in New York under police escort
as confirmed Kovac 19 cases keep
climbing this is a gun city and state
officials continue their frantic search
for protective gear for medical
personnel and ventilators for the
growing number of critically ill with
none left to purchase New York's
governor promised to sign an executive
order allowing the state to take the
devices from hospitals not currently
using them I'm not going to let people
die because we didn't redistribute
ventilators the National Guard are going
to be deployed to pick up these
ventilators which are all across the
state and deployed them to places where
we need them
hospitals in New York City are bearing
the brunt of the outbreak with lines for
testing and overwhelmed emergency rooms
statewide almost 600 people died in one
day even as a temporary hospital set up
at a convention center sits empty and
the u.s. comfort Navy hospital ship
holds just 20 patients both were set up
for non Kovan patients the governor said
that will change for the convention
center soon as it turned out we don't
have non colvett people to any great
extent in the hospitals hospitals have
now turned into effectively ICU
hospitals for kovat patients so we
wanted to convert Javits from non Kovac
to Kovac
New York's mayor advised city residents
to wear masks in public places amid
growing evidence that infected people
who don't show symptoms can still
transmit the disease but the governor
cautioned there was no clear evidence to
support the move might it help I think
it's here to say yes but don't get a
full sense of security one glimmer of
hope researchers have begun collecting
blood plasma from recovered kovat 19
patients like Tiffany pickney for an
experimental treatment
they hope the antibodies developed in
her blood can be used to bolster the
immune systems of the infected there may
be answers for researchers there may be
answers for people who are laying in a
hospital bed not knowing what's going to
happen to them tomorrow so it is
definitely a humbling experience and I'm
honored that could be just what doctors
need Kristen salumi al Jazeera New York